hello everyone thank you for joining us
for seniors is 2nd annual virtual
symposium advances in drug discovery and
development I'm stupor Minh senior
correspondent CD news and I'm delighted
to introduce our next speaker Vic Meyer
chief technology officer at edit oz
medicine Vic Meyer earned a BS in
biochemistry from Cornell University and
a PhD in molecular biophysics and
biochemistry from Yale University and
then served as a postdoctoral research
associate at MIT zweite head institute
for biomedical research he held various
royals at corning and was senior
scientist for millennium pharmaceuticals
he was a founding scientists and group
leader at excel II a systems biology
company focusing on commercialization of
a high-throughput cell-based microarray
technology about a decade ago he joined
the novartis institutes for biomedical
research as a research investigator he
later headed novartis high-throughput
biology and target discovery
technologies and most recently served as
executive director and Cambridge
Cambridge site head for the
developmental and molecular pathways
department which he led away we led a
team of over 200 scientists he joined
editors medicine earlier this year Vic
please go ahead
thank you for the introductions do and
I'd like to thank the organizers for
inviting me to present today it's a real
privilege and I think it's a really
interesting platform for sharing
information in the scientific community
from the comfort of your own office in
your own desk although I have to say on
a personal note is very bizarre to be
speaking to my monitor right now and
certainly the folks in the hallway who
have been walking by are asking all
sorts of questions so it's a bit odd I'd
say this presentation is a logical
follow on from a presentation that was
given by Fung Zhang who's one of the
founders of edit oz medicine funk
presented I think last year in this
forum and gave a really nice overview of
the crisper Cassadine technology that
the company is founded on and really
sort of i think highlighted a lot of
biological applications and uses for the
technology and I think as most of you
who dialed in probably know Chris Burke
s9 is really creating a revolution in in
the world of biology it's it's sort of
swept through the research and discovery
areas like marriage new technologies
have before and I do honestly think it's
one of those sort of once in a lifetime
or once every decade sort of biology
discoveries I'm not going to talk much
to all about crisper Cassadine these
signs of the specific endonuclease today
I'm going to talk about what we're doing
aneta tops which is working to translate
this biology revolution into what we
hope is going to be a therapeutic
revolution so the so the mission of the
company is to create a novel class of
therapeutics that precisely correct the
underlying cause of a broad range of
genetic diseases and I think as as many
of you know
the ability to correct genetic mutations
has long been a goal of Medicine I think
since scientists started cloning genes
and describing mutations and really
understanding that mutations can cause
disease it's been an aspiration for us
to be able to correct that and of course
many of the drugs that are on the market
can correct very few of the root cause
mutations of the disease but I think
there's really sort of a unique
confluence of events that have come
together come together to allow us to
aspire to to actually try to reach this
this goal and there's three things in
particular I want to highlight the first
of course is the the advent of
sequencing technologies the application
and understanding that we've achieved in
human genetics and really the collection
and understanding of phenotypic and
clinical data associated with diverse
sets of diseases really sets the stage
for us to understand to understand the
the root cause of the drivers of
genetics the second is that the field of
gene fields of gene therapy and nucleic
acid therapies have really come a long
way in terms of being able to deliver
very complex payloads and very complex
car goes to a diverse set of areas in
the body and that's a lot of the work
that's going to help us leverage our
technology to generate therapies and
finally genome editing is not new it's
been going on for a long time but I
think the advent of the crisper cast
nine system in the discovery of the
system has really positioned us to
rapidly go after and try to solve some
of these fundamental problems so let me
just in one slide summarize the
technology that we're working with
primarily a teddy toss medicine which is
a protein RNA complex called cast nine
which is part of the crisper system and
addicts at its core it's a
double-stranded
nuclease cast 9 is on its own it has
very little to no DNA binding and
cleavage activity that DNA binding
activity is provided entranced by an RNA
molecule in the iteration that we're
using the technology it's a single guide
RNA molecule and that guide RNA molecule
binds the protein and imparts upon it
the DNA binding specificity so that it
can find and target the double-stranded
portion of it of the genome that's
complementary to the first five prime
end of the of the guide RNA so
originally cast 9 was discovered cast 9
the crisper system is part of the
bacterial adaptive immune system it's a
system where bacteria have evolved to
sort of grab on to invading DNA at it
from bacteriophage or plasmids and then
take that DNA they stuff it in their own
genome is sort of a storage mechanism
then this DNA upon subsequent infection
by it by an invader is is transcribed in
the case of the type to crisper systems
the the RNA is bound by the protein and
directs it to cleave the internal the
invading phage or DNA plasmid so so
again it's a programmable nuclease where
the specificity is provided by a guide
RNA that's in trance to the protein
molecule I do have two diagrams here of
the molecule shown the upper left is a
beautiful crystal traffic image that I
grabbed from the Anders 2014 nature
paper shown in blue the blue trace is
the protein shown in green is the guide
RNA and shown in red is the
double-stranded target DNA and on the
right is is simply a cartoon schematic
of the protein where the guide RNA is
shown in the bottom hybridizing to the
double-stranded DNA target shown in the
middle of a molecule importantly after
the cleavage event happens within the
cell the cells natural DNA repair
machinery takes over to repair that
cleavage event and really there are two
grossly speaking two possibilities in
terms of how the cell responds the first
is by a process called non-homologous
end joining and this is a a relatively
efficient but in precise mechanism where
the cell stitches the double-stranded
cut back together so during this process
the the cell will often do this in an
error-prone matter and it will create
small insertions and deletions at the
site of cleavage and so this can be
incredibly an incredibly important and
efficient way to knock out jeans because
if we target the site of cleavage to an
open reading frame that the resulting
small insertions and deletions will
actually disrupt the coding sequence of
that gene causing a loss of function the
other less predominant pathway is called
homology directive repair and this is
the process by which the cell uses a
complementary DNA as a template to
incorporate a new essentially reparative
piece of DNA so it's a way we can
correct genes as opposed to disrupt them
and it's an important thing to
understand for the audience that there
are two different pathways we can go
down one which is in precise and is
generally targeted toward knocking out
function and another which is about
repairing function and ultimately we
believe and I think others would
probably agree that to fully realize the
promise of the technology we're going to
need to be able to harness the homology
directed repair pathway
okay so within the company we've created
sort of a dynamic relationship between
creating medicines and developing the
technology we're a product company a
medicine company but were built on a
strong technology platform so the goal
is for the medicines group is to provide
first-in-class therapeutics and also to
create indications that will require
advancement development of the
technology while on the technology side
we aspire your best in class in terms of
a platform and we also aspire to invent
and create innovation that will expand
education for our genome editing
medicines and we generally think about
three questions as we develop and drive
our strategy the first is what can we do
today so given the state of the art and
where we are what therapies can we work
on and what can we develop with what we
have the second piece is which disease
indications are springboards for
expansion within that therapeutic area
and you can imagine as we develop
delivery modalities and we develop the
ability to edit different create
different kinds of penance in different
tissues we can start with a with
treating one disease and then we can
expand within that that tissue type or
within that therapeutic area and finally
we think a lot about improvements in
technology space and which improvements
will most broadly expand our
capabilities and this comes back to
really sort of a push poll of the
creation of new medicines and the
development of the technology we're
fundamentally a product company again
built on a strong technology base okay
so when do over the next two slides just
talk a little bit about the platform and
a little bit about how we think about
the therapeutics and how we select what
we work on and then I'll walk through
two examples of more advanced programs
that we're working on the first is an ex
vivo application where we redditing
t-cells in collaboration with Juno
therapeutics and the second is an
integral application where we're editing
within the subretinal space of rods and
cones
of the i-44 a inherited optical vision
disorder so in the platform space we
divide the platform into four key areas
or four key facets if you will the first
is is what we call molecular engineering
so this is all the nuts and bolts of the
crisper castaign system itself it's the
protein creation of the protein
purification if needs to be done
chemistry and biochemistry engineering
and evolution of the protein and
similarly with the guidance nucleic acid
chemistry at sky design it's it's all
the modifications that one can make to
enhance function of the guide RNA it's
also where we do all of our lead finding
activities so finding the best
combination of enzyme and guide or
guides to solve a given problem and
finally where we do all of our
specificity work so it's obviously an
important part of our technology
platform once we've sort of defined what
the package looks like we then worked up
to think about delivery and I'll talk a
little bit more in detail about delivery
but what I essentially diagrammed here
is a cartoon of a virus and a cartoon of
a lipid nanoparticle and that's simply
remind me to tell you that we're not a
delivery company but we are working with
and licensing in delivery technologies
that have been developed over the last
20 years to solve nucleic acid and gene
gene augmentation sort of strategies and
so we're where we were not afraid to
develop new delivery technologies but
it's not where we're choosing to invest
right now beyond delivery is this idea
of regulation and I think this is a
really important idea to impress on the
audience in contrast to Jane
augmentation therapies or nucleic acid
therapies where you're looking for
prolonged expression or prolonged
suppression of your target we actually
want to have very tight control over the
activity and the pharmacokinetics of our
editing our bar editing enzyme in our
editing package we want to have the
package delivered we want to do its job
correct the deficit or knock out the
gene of interest in the genome and then
disappear right so so this is actually
in stark contrast to a lot of the other
modalities today that I mentioned before
one chin augmentation or nucleic
acid-based repression but I think as we
talk to people it's relatively
straightforward to take something that
already works reasonably well like some
of the existing delivery technologies
and actually turn it back down and so we
have a bunch of programs internally to
to specifically address this and finally
the last piece in the platform that we
are focused on and this is a strong
commitment for for the company is
harnessing the the ability for the cell
to repair the double-stranded break
using homology directed repair as
opposed to not on august and joining and
again I think this is going to
ultimately be an important component of
creating the most value and being able
to treat the most patients with the
genome editing technology so I'll shift
gears and talk a bit about tell me how
we think about diseases and biology we
think about as we select what we're
going to work on we think about medical
need in these four basic categories
there's I'm sorry the programs of these
four basic categories there's medical
need there's the biology and clinical
regulatory components there's delivery
and then there's the editing technology
itself so we like to work on things
they're not currently being addressed
adequately by existing therapeutic
modalities and we want to ultimately be
able to generate a differentiated
product so if something is potentially
treatable by gene augmentation therapy
for example it might not be the best
indication for us if it happens to the
very large gene that you
would have a hard time delivering using
conventional delivery technologies that
might be a good place for us to dig in
on the biology side and the clinical
side we really want to be going after
diseases where we understand the natural
history of the disease because that will
translate into understanding how much
editing we need and where we need to
have that editing happen so for example
recessive disorders where a wild-type
allele covering the recessive allele the
individual is normal in his carrier
where a homozygous recessive is affected
with the disease gives us a tip that
that fifty percent rescue rescue of it's
one of the alleles as opposed to both of
alleles should be sufficient to to
restore gene function we also of course
need access to patients in order to
carry out clinical trials and we want to
be able to have an appropriate treatment
window so that we can see efficacy in
the clinic in a time frame where we can
understand what what's what's happening
with with our therapy you know this is a
new technology and it's a new
therapeutic modality and suddenly we're
going to we're going to learn a lot in
the claim and so we need to be able to
sort of generate through that process of
creating creating a drug and testing
that drug in the clinic as I mentioned a
delivery space we would like to use
things that are clinically validated and
specific for target cell and tissue type
and we need to be able to work and
understand efficiency and specificity
requirements and the sort of amount
required for the vector and the dose and
finally on the editing side we need to
go after things that are within reach
today while we set up programs to access
technologies and then access different
repairs in the future we also forgive a
disease need to understand sort of human
genetics of the situation are we looking
at high prevalence of a common mutation
or there many many mutations spanning a
we would need to to deal with okay so
starting to jump into the data again
there are two possibilities on the
delivery side our strategy is to select
the right mode for the problem at hand
so when we think about ex vivo
cell-based therapies of course there are
a lot of different methods by which we
can deliver in vivo we are a bit more
restricted and then the i'm just showing
sort of the different formats here once
we think about a given format there's of
course different ways that that can also
be delivered so for example the people
we can either think about systemic
delivery of you think about localized
delivery etc so just to start on the ex
vivo side of the programs I just
diagrammed here are four different
possibilities we can deliver a plasmid
so that's the basic idea i should say
here is is we would extract cells from
the patient mood edit those ship cells
and then we would put them back into the
into the patient's though it's
essentially an autologous cell cell
therapy based approach we could encode
the cast nine protein in the guide RNAs
and a plasma and introduced a plasmid we
could use an awl RNA approach where we
encode the cast on on messenger RNA and
couple that with a synthetic guide RNA
we could imagine RNA protein complex
approach and RNP approach where we pre
complex the guide RNA with the cast nine
enzyme or finally we can think about a
viral vector to use XP go to deliver a
virus that encodes for both the protein
in the guide RNAs so I'm going to talk
about the work that we've done with Juno
therapeutics today it's about a three
and a half month old collaboration but I
think hope you'd agree that we've seen
some exciting results and the
collaborations advancing quite quickly
so as probably many of you know Juno is
one of the world leaders in using
engineered t cells to treat cancer using
both the chimeric antigen receptor
technology the car technology as well as
the t cell receptor or TCR technology
platform and essentially there is an
autologous cell therapy strategy where
they will take cells from the blood of
patients they will select the cell type
that's required for the therapy and
activate that cell type they'll
introduce a gene that adds a new
function into that t-cell so it might
activate the T cell when the t-cell
encounters a specific antigen on a tumor
or on a cancer cell they'll then
activate those cells and infuse them
back into the patient an entire idea of
the collaboration for us is to integrate
gene editing to enhance the t-cell
function in the ex vivo portion of the
process so we and Juno believe that
there are certain targets that we can go
after to either knock them out or change
them such that that the modification of
those targets will positively affect the
ability of the t-cell therapy to to to
remove the cancer from the patient into
essentially for the patient ok so we
started out this program looking into
delivery and we knew we were going to be
ex vivo from the start we looked at a
number of different systems and and
essentially we needed to have a scalable
delivery system that could integrate
into their current workflow we looked at
a couple different things but ultimately
settled on the mac side electroporation
system this is a nice system because we
can run it a small scale and it's it is
scalable up to therapeutic uses it's in
our hands given high transfection
efficiency and good cell viability and
I'll walk you through some of that data
moving forward just show on the bottom
left hand side is a fax plot of
of jurkat cells which are transformed t
cell line where we introduce the
messenger RNA that encodes either cats 9
shown in black or gfp shown in red and
you can see we get a really nice shift
in fluorescence and we get very high
transduction efficiency in a control
experiment so as we started to look into
knocking out therapeutical
therapeutically relevant targets and i
should say up front I apologize i am
masking the name to the targets because
we're not ready to disclose the names of
the targets and we're working on
together so you'll see them generically
called target or target area or target
be i should say all the targets were
working on can be probed using facts and
so you'll see facts data in the next
several slides okay so back to looking
at delivery the two approaches that we
focused on initially we're either an all
RNA approach where we encoded the cast
nine on a messenger RNA and coupled that
with a guide RNA and delivered that to
the cells by electroporation or an RNP
where we pre complex the RNA with the
protein and the results of this are
shown on the left hand side so this is
just a time course of jurkat cells that
are treated with either the all RNA
formulation in the lighter shade of
orange and the rmv formulation in the
darker orange dark red color and what
you can just see is we get pretty good
percent editing I should mention that
this essay is a targeted on target essay
called t71 so this is a mismatch
sensitive endonuclease that cleans DNA
went when it's got a mismatch it's a
standard editing essay in the field and
we get pretty good editing from both
delivery technologies between thirty and
fifty percent knockout in the target of
interest in this case and if you look at
the toxicity on the right both of them
gave read a reasonable response in
toxicity so we didn't see a large die
off and the cells seem to recover i
would say in this one experiment the way
it's plotted it looks like the mRNA
actually
had a lower viability but this did not
stand up and repeat experiments and we
we now conclude that both messenger RNA
and RNP have equal equally toxic or
basically non toxic effects on on the
jurkat cells at least okay so given this
data we decided to focus on our NP and I
think strategically just makes sense
because it also gives us more control
over the regulation of the molecule but
kinetics of the molecule it will be
cleared from the t-cells more quickly in
theory it also allows us to chemically
modify the protein if we are interested
in doing so and so now we're moving into
primary human t cells so these are cd4
positive T cells that we are editing
with a target of interest and shown on
the top is the is the fax plot so top
left is the isotype control the center
is a control guide RNA that's targeting
a different chain and on the top right
is a guide RNA that is targeting the
target of interest those two facts plots
on the top right are represented on the
bottom left looking at target expression
and what you can see is a pretty nice
shift again we are probing the target of
interest here a pretty nice shift in the
control versity versus the targeting
guide RNA when we go in with that t71
acid that i mentioned before on the
bottom right you see about 50% editing
which if you look at the facts pot is
actually a little bit confusing because
it looks like it's much greater than
fifty percent so we did go ahead and use
a sequencing based approach to confirm
the editing events that we saw and
actually it turned out that we were
under estimating
editing using the t71 essay and this is
a common challenge in the field in in
that if you get a lot of editing and
those edits are a very common in nature
they will appear as unedited duplexes to
the t71 essay because of course they
perfectly hybridize to each other so
we've moved into Sanger sequencing and
targeted sequencing for all of the
subsequent analyses because we were
already we were already maxing out the
capability of the t71 si2 to recognize
the editing events so to make sure this
wasn't a one-hit wonder we've gone
through two additional targets here the
fact sponsor and the other orientation
the top left is a control where we've
actually knocked out the target in the
previous a saying you can see it has no
effect on this target and then we knock
out target a and target B and we see
reduction in fluorescence in in the
facts plot for target a with one
knocking out of target a and target
being wood knocking out of target B and
this data is summarized on the on the
bottom and what I'm showing is percent
viability on the left hand side and so
you can see an unedited or a control the
control edited cells are have a similar
profile as the target cells on the right
hand side you can see the percent
knockdown is measured by sequencing and
so here we see a slightly different
kinetics and we're not sure if that's a
biology result or if that's actually a
delayed kinetics of editing meaning the
edited cells actually outgrow on it in
cells with target a which is different
than the previous target we are at about
ninety percent edited cells by day four
and with target B were around sixty six
fifty five fifty sixty percent and so
we're still working on making this a
more robust result if you will so to
confirm that this was not restricted to
cd4 positive T cells we both have done
this with cd8 positive T cells and we
get very similar results to see these
are the same two targets as shown on the
previous slide I should say the same
three
Sean the previous slide and this is the
viability in the editing data so target
a is still the one that's easiest to
knock out with the guy that we're using
and target B is less so but we can work
in both cd8 positive and cd4 positive T
cells finally we need to start
understanding Doretha donor variability
and so this is an experiment we're
laughter those same two targets in three
different donors so this data looks just
like the previous data the only
exception is that we have error bars on
here and these are error bars are
derived from different donors down the
same day so these are essentially true
biological replicates in that they're
entirely different t cells derived cd4
positive T cells derived from different
donors and this is encouraging to us
because this is across a relatively
broad age range and blood types etc so
so we're continuing to to dig in on this
data okay so that's where we are with
the Juno program we're really able to
edit at 90 plus percent efficiency
ex-vivo with primary T cells quite
excited about that we're working with
our partners now to assess the biology
function of these edited cells to
understand if they're doing the biology
that we imagine that they are actually
doing so we're working hard with our
partners to do that okay so let's shift
gears a bit too in an EVO circumstance
so the disease we're working on here is
called Leber's congenital amaurosis type
10 or lc8 n the collection of libris
diseases is a heterogeneous group of
inherited retinal destroy dystrophies
and it's the leading cause of childhood
blindness there are at least 14
different described genes that can have
mutations in in those genes that cause
this disease so while it's characterized
as a single disease there's clearly
different genetic drivers LCM 10 is a
homozygous recessive disorder so the
parents are generally normally
characters and they they have done many
Liam relationship in terms of the
creating offspring that have that carry
to defective alleles of the gene the
gene responsible for LCA 10 is a gene
called set to 90 set to 90 is it protein
that's involved with Sarah Genesis and
it's important for maintaining ciliary
structure and function and that's an
important component of photoreceptor
brought rod and cone function so shown
on the top right is just a retinal
cross-section from a normal person on
the top you can see in purple
highlighted the layer of the layer of
rods and cones in the retina and it's
with the central phobia highlighted
where you get your high high high
central vision acuity from and when you
can see in the bottom is a section at
cross-sectional recep 290 patient and
what you see is peripheral loss of cones
and then that peripheral loss over time
and the patient continues to migrate
from the outside in until these patients
end up being totally blind by the age by
their mid-20s at the age of 30 so
children are often born with this
disorder they do have they have a rapid
loss of the rods than the constant
earier eight between in their
adolescence and into the early adulthood
and end up as completely blind it's
important to note that the central
photoreceptors are maintained in our
functional so the goal for us is to
target these photoreceptors and correct
the mutation in set to 90 so that we can
hopefully allow these photoreceptors to
survive
okay so this is a good place for us to
storm the new technology new therapeutic
there are no therapies available it's a
relatively large gene at 7.5 k be so
it's larger than the packaging women of
the atom associated virus there are
proximal end points we can do within the
clinic so we can measure visual acuity
very accurately within the clinic we can
set up very well internally controlled
clinical trials where we can treat one
eye and not treat the other eye the eye
of course is an immune privileged organ
AMD has been used in Jinan mentation
therapies in the clinic and it's been
shown to be safe and effective and we
are currently partnered on this program
with the lab of dr. bud Tucker at the
University of Iowa and the University of
Iowa and by Tucker are experts in and
these sorts of therapeutic approaches
I'll talk a bit about the editing that
we're doing but we're also working with
but on ex vivo models for both efficacy
and toxicity so in terms of the biology
again it's a large gene and intron 26
spans the two exons exon 26 and 27 of
course in the course of normal normal
people we had normal transcription and
splicing to get the correct set to 90
protein the mutation of the most common
LCA 10 causing mutation is actually a
single point mutation in within the
intron it's highlighted in blue with the
the red star over it and this actually
causes a change in the splicing pattern
so you get creation of a novel splice
acceptor activation of a splice donor
and what happens is you get inclusion of
a novel exon of 128 base pairs between X
on 26 and X I'm 27 and this creates an
in-frame stop codon which then creates a
truncated non functional protein okay so
this is our editing strategy we're
actually using a dual guide editing
strategy so we're going in and with with
a double-stranded to double-stranded
endonucleases so it's one cast iron
molecule with two guides we're directing
those cast iron molecules to cut on
either
I of the mutation and essentially remove
that mutation so for us it's a deep in
tronic mutation this is not shown to
scale so i should say this about a
thousand 1kv chunk that we're cutting
output so it's a pretty large intron so
we're nowhere near the the exon intron
boundaries the editing itself doesn't
need to be precise we just need to clip
out this one kv region so the ideas will
cut out this region and will eliminate
the cryptic splice and splicing pattern
and we'll get a correct section on any
protein expression the product prototype
that we're working with is is the
subretinal injection of a single ad
vector this is two different guide RNAs
directing the enzyme to the two
different cut sites driven by the u6
promoter and we're using the staff
workers cast nine and I should mention
the staph aureus cast nine is a newly
described cast nine that was
characterized in thong Zhang's lab and
we've done additional work that is in
review process right now to publish the
sort of in-depth character age
characterization of the staph aureus
cast nine this is an important enzyme
for us because it's over kami smaller
than the pyogenes cast nine and
therefore it gives us more real estate
in the ad no associated viral vectoring
system so we can incorporate more
functionality in that a V vector so
here's some data so this is a measuring
the proportion of knock out of that one
kb fragment and these are guide RNA
pairs shown across the x-axis with the
gfp control on the right hand side these
are patient-derived fibroblasts so these
are actually very difficult to transfer
cell and so so we only get about ten to
twenty percent deletion we're asking
this using a digital drop of PCR
standard a saying system won't work in
this case because we're deleting a very
large fragment so we have to go to an
alternate readout technology in control
cell lines like hek293 zouri 20 s as we
do see between thirty and fifty percent
editing so we think that this is
essentially a
challenge that we're facing here but we
thought it was important to do this in
patient to write fiberglass to
understand if if we're actually
correcting correcting these mutations
this is the effect of that's in the same
fiberglass of doing an editing on
messenger RNA expression so shown on the
right hand side is imported right hand
side are the controls of the messenger
RNA amount for the messages in green and
for the wild-type is in blue so in the
patient's you do have some wild type
protein because you get some normal
splicing but the predominance of
splicing is is that the the cryptic
splice site i should say it's our
hypothesis although we haven't formally
proven this that the mutant messenger
RNA is actually less stable than the
wild-type so this is a misrepresentation
of the level of transcription this is of
course a steady-state snapshot of the
levels of messenger RNA but what you can
see when we perform the editing and
again we're only editing it between the
ten and twenty percent range we're
getting a good to a three-fold increase
of the wild-type amount of messenger RNA
as shown in this slide and here is the
protein expression data so it's a
Western blot on the left and a
quantitative Western on the right we're
seeing a good two ish fold increase in
the amount of protein wild-type protein
I should comment that this antibody
actually only recognizes the c-terminus
of the protein so it would not recognize
the mutant form of the set to 90 so oh I
forgot to mention I did mention
initially that this was a protein that's
involved in cilia genesis and so this is
simply a slide demonstrating that we're
we're building a silly Genesis ass I
ought to be staying patient fibroblasts
and shown in the it's a high content
imaging assay where we're staining with
three colors daddy for nuclei acetylene
tubulin and gamma tubulin for for
visualizing the cilia you can see in the
top left blow up a nice sillier
formation with the
red satellite tubulin and gamma tubulin
cilia on the right you can see the
patient dr fibroblasts have have sort of
essentially defective looking cilia and
we can quantitate those as shown below
where we're counting the percentage of
cells that have cilia on the left hand
graph and then we're measuring for the
cells that have silly at what the length
of you silly it is so we're currently
the experiments to rescue this phenotype
are ongoing and we're also working with
our collaborators at the University of
Iowa to take these into ex vivo models
that the university has available and
into some preclinical animal models so
I'll wrap it up there hopefully you've
got a good feeling for what we're doing
at etosha medicine we're focused on
translating what's a biology revolution
into being a therapeutic revolution with
Juno we've demonstrated effective ex
vivo editing of primary human t cells
and we're moving those programs forward
to test for functional consequences of
that cell editing and finally for our
for one of our internal programs that I
talked about the LCA 10 set to 90 we've
developed functional on 180 vectors and
we're advancing those into model systems
so I will stop and take any questions
and thank you all for watching and I'll
turn it over the YouTube
okay thanks Vic I was a bit of a
incompetent host in that I missed part
of my introduction so I was supposed to
tell all the attendees that you can ask
questions and luckily some of you
realize that you could do that even
without my having said anything I was
supposed to tell you I would be back
after bix talk to moderate a Q&A session
so here I am and you can click on the
Q&A button on your screen if you don't
have any questions and we do have some
already that I'll ask I was also
supposed to say that see any news does
not endorse any company products or
services that may be mentioned in this
presentation or that have been mentioned
in this case and that the talk will be
archived and available on demand at the
conference website for three months
after this live broadcast until December
16 2015 so don't go there on December
17th ok so now I'm going to ask a few
questions that I have and feel free to
ask more now that I finally finished my
introduction that I was supposed to do
before one question I do have is a
couple of gene editing techniques for
example zinc fingers talons tal yen's
predate crisper with it whatever that is
I don't know exist for you know other
techniques exist for gene editing do
they hold any technological or
therapeutic advantages over crisper cast
9 dick
okay I think that's a good question and
of course we get that a lot you know I
think towns and zinc fingers have been
around for longer have people been
working on a longer so so they are a bit
closer to being tried in the clinic so
they are a bit ahead of this technology
because it's the new technology I think
where we really feel the strength of
this technology is is in a couple of
different places the first is the easy
program ability of the nuclease by
virtue of creating multiple guide RNAs
is incredibly helpful for us early in
the process we can try a large number of
different guide RNAs and thereby enzymes
to understand what the what the best
combination is to move forward as a
therapeutic and so there's a certain
flexibility to the system and a nuance
that I didn't go into is there are
different isoforms of the enzyme that
are mutant in one of the two and the
nuclease domains so we have at our
disposal what we call Nick cases so
these are proteins that would cut only
one of the two strands and in the same
way we're using to guide RNAs for the
set to 90 program we can program the
nucleus to create Nick's on opposite
sides of the strands and we can vary
both the location and the nature of the
kinds of overhangs that we get and it
turns out in data we've disclosed
elsewhere the ability to create those
different overhangs actually has a
fundamental effect on how the cell
responds to those cuts and I think those
are things that are a bit more difficult
to to engender with the other
technologies because for you to try
multiple proteins you multiply into
nucleases you have to engineer them each
individually and so that becomes sort of
a
a rate-limiting step okay thanks next
question is will the CEP 290 targeting
be used as a therapeutic or a
prophylactic treatment the idea is is
we're going to get we're going to sorry
let me start all over again so for us
the idea is that will go into patients
who are diagnosed at the molecular level
to have the SEP 290 mutation and we'll
treat them in the initial clinical
trials will treat them sort of in the in
the adolescent stage or in the in their
in their early teens we haven't defined
this exactly in order to preserve those
those photoreceptors so the initial
incarnation is not something that we're
going to give to newborns for example it
is something where we will do a proof of
concept in the clinic in in older
patients to try to preserve preserve
their their vision for the remainder of
their lives so I guess the answer is
therapeutic so I guess the answer
okay sorry we got switched over all
right how long have you seen the edits
stay in the system have you monitored
long-term long-term knockout of the
genes so that's that's a good question I
think in that case it entirely depends
on the turnover of the the cell itself
so for example for example in a
terminally differentiated cells such as
in the case of a photoreceptor cell
which are not continually turning over
we anticipate that once the once the
cell is edited it will it will stay
edited for the look for the life of the
cell and presumably the the life of the
patient it in terms of rapidly dividing
sell the edits will stay of course in
the progeny but if the organ for example
is is rapidly dividing and unedited and
edited cells divide at an equal pace you
will see essentially a dilution as as an
organ grows four cells are rapidly
turned over if we don't hit a stem cell
or or a significant portion of cells
will have to readmit astir the
the drugs okay that's all the time we
have I'm told many thanks to vick Moya
for his presentation and thanks to all
of you for tuning in there will be more
talks beginning at the top of the hour
and throughout the day you can find the
full program on the agenda page located
on the upper right hand side of your
screen in the meantime please stop by
the virtual exhibit hall and the lounge
to check out our sponsors and exhibitors
or to network with other attendees join
the conversation on twitter with hashtag
cen SYM 15 stands for cen symposium 15
cen SYM 15 thank you and goodbye